at the 116 Acre Central Florida zoo
keepers with the exotic birds struggled
to catch a stubborn Caracara it was all
for the birds own good
we got about 450 animals zoo director
Dino fairy's responsible for keeping
them safe who's the hardest to coax into
there the monkeys the guenons they're a
little more skittish some animals like
the Rhinos and giraffes will be kept in
their normal sleeping quarters and ferry
hopes they'll stay put what animal are
you most concerned about potentially
escaping during the hurricane would be
probably any of our carnivores you know
the big cats down south that Zoo Miami
Diesel the cheetah is safe inside a
hurricane proof space the zoo houses
more than 3,000 animals including a
flock of pink flamingos who were moved
to a concrete bunker ahead of the storm
it's a step up from the 90s when
employees were forced to herd the
flamingos into bathrooms during
hurricanes Andrew George and Floyd not
my first time I was in New Orleans
during Katrina what did you learn from
Hurricane Katrina I never want to be in
a hurricane again ferry worked at the
Audubon zoo in New Orleans when Katrina
hit it's surreal what we learned is
preparation we prepare we have crisis
management plan with the start of the
season you people start looking for
things that could be flying objects
it's just preparation